[音楽]
みなさんこんにちは
こんにちは三重大学を卒業してから6年が経ち
ここ山水ホールでお話できることを非常に光栄に思います
今日は歩くということをテーマにお話ししたいと思います
皆さんの中で歩いたことがあるという方はいらっしゃいますでしょうか
歩いたことがあるという方は手を上げていただけますでしょうか
ありがとうございます当たり前ですね
なぜなら人が人になったのはあるいたからなんですね
人は脳が大きくなってから足が歩くになったのか
歩くようになってからがのが大きくなったのか人類学者の中でも論争がありました
しかしこの
脳が小さいけれども二足歩行のヒトの祖先が見つかってから
歩くようになってから手を使うようになり脳が大きくなったことがわかっています
人の足というのは非常に複雑かつ不安定な構造しています
片足だけでも骨が28困るんですねなので人の足っていうのはただそこに安定して立つ
ためじゃなくて歩くためにあるんだなぁということがその構造からわかります
ただその場にいるだけだったらトカゲのようにご重心を低くして説明席を増やした方が
効率的なんです
まあそんなことをしているのは家でダラダラしてる時だけなんですね
今日はその歩き方について皆さんとお話ししたいなと思うんですけれども皆さん歩き方
について意識したことはありますでしょうか
あまりにも当たり前のことなのであまり意識したことがないかもしれません
さん宅でお答えいただきたいんですが自分の歩き方がきれいか皆さんご存知かちょっと
教えていただきたいんです
自分の在り方はきれいかふつーか綺麗ではないかのこのさん宅でお願いします
直感で結構です
自分の歩き方は綺麗だと思う方は手を挙げてください
自分のある方は普通だという方は
中のある方はきれいではないという方は
まあまあ綺麗じゃない人が終えるとが分かりましたね
かっこいい私は
自分のある方はとても綺麗だと思ってたんですね
その私が初めてウォーキングトレーダーの指導を受けたところ極めて歩き方が汚いと
いうことが分かりました
非常に驚きでした
ただですね歩き方が綺麗ではないのは私だけではありません
100人の路上調査を行いました
そうするとなんと5割もの人が歩き方が綺麗ではないということが分かりました
改善の余地がある人も含めるとなんと8割にものぼります
実際に見ていきましょう
こちらの男性は足を投げるように歩いてますね
ちゃってます
こちらの女性は膝をこうくねくねと内側にいれるように歩いています
内股も一人ですね
これを掘っていくとどうなるか
膝や腰が痛みます
関節にわずかな負担が少しずつかかっていくことでじわじわと骨が変形し最終的に痛み
に至ります
これは私が先月見た実際に患者さんのレントゲン写真なんですけれども
このように骨が変形してしまってからでは妄想いいんですね
病院に来た頃にはもう手遅れなんです
ん
例えば生活習慣が悪いと生活習慣病になり脳梗塞に至るのと同じなんです
日々の体の使い方が悪いと
徐々に骨が変形し痛みに至ります
痛くなってからでは遅いんです
ですので例えば腰痛で整形外科を受診したのに治療に満足しなかったという人はなんと
45%に置いてあります
この数字は私たち1円推しにとって不名誉な数字だなと思えてなりません
あの膝のおばあちゃんももっと自分の足を大切にしておけばよかったと言った言葉が
非常に印象的でした
こういった膝や腰が痛い人が今どのくらいいるかご存じでしょうか
世界では膝の痛みは4%を腰の痛みは10%いると分かっています
世界の人口は76億人なのでざっと10億人の人が困っています
日本は高齢化しているのでもっと多いです
ひざの痛みは1800万人腰の痛みは2800万人とも言われます
高齢者の2人に1人が傷んでいますので皆さんの中からも足腰がいたも可能性もあり
ます
じゃあどうすれば予防することができるでしょうか
それは綺麗に体を使うことです
特に人の動作の最も基本である歩き方を綺麗にすることです
ではなぜ私は自分の歩き方が間違ってきれいだと勘違いしていたのでしょうか
私が自惚れていたという可能性も十分あります
ただそれだけでは5割もの人があり方が汚いという理由にはちょっとなりません
深掘りするなかで私は一つ気づいたことがあります
それは
自分の歩き方は見えないということなんです
自分の歩き方が見えないので評価ができません
評価ができなければ改善のサイクルがもありません
結果が返ってこない事件を受けるようなもんですね皆さんテストを受ける時に必ず
答え合わせをしたと思います
あれがやはり大事です
逆に言えば自分の歩き方が見えるようになれば
効果良くないなと分かってきれいに歩けるようになります
そこで私は会社を立ち上げ歩き方を可視化する
製品をつくりました
それがこのミラー多くです
カメラの前をただ歩くだけで歩き方が可視化されます
右の画面で自分のシルエットが見え左の画面で自分のスコアが分かります
実際に見ていきましょう
ハルクとリアルタイムに自分のシルエットが見えます
この子ルートを見て自分のある方をチェックすることができます
左は自分の評価が点数で出てきますし下にはワンポイントアドバイスをして
どのようにしていれば綺麗に歩けるようになるかがわかります
地目写真のはこの自分が綺麗に歩けば綺麗にあるほど後ろがきらきら光るというところ
がかわいいところだなと思っています
ただですね歩き方をきれいにするというのは結構時間がかかるんですね
なので今アプリも作っています
実は世界初のキレイになれるウォーキングレスアプリです
たとえばテニスの練習をする時に本を読んでから後で転出の練習をするよりも
テニスをしながらテニスの仕方襲った方が上手くなります
歩き方も同じです歩きながら歩き方を剃った方が上手くなります
このアプリは歩きながらトレーナーのレッスンを聞くだけです
例えばこんな感じ今回のレッスンは太もものの日です
太ももの上 v ラインのあたりを伸ばして歩きましょう
音楽を聴くような感じでいきます
太ももが伸びて歩幅が大きくなっていれば ok です
体が上下にバウンドしないように注意しましょう
粉にトレーナーが言うようにそのままにやっていけば自然ときれいに歩けるようになり
ます
音楽を聴くようにできるので月時間や通学時間に聞きながらそれだけで出来てしまうん
です
このアプリは9月にリリースを予定しています
ただですね
綺麗に歩くっていうのはあの
若ければ若いほどいいんですけど若ければ若いほど
痛みを予防するっていうのはなかなか目的になりづらいんですね
優先順位が低いんです
ただ実は
綺麗に歩くっていうのは健康に良いだけではないんです
このスライドをご覧下さい
同じ女性で右側と左側で見比べていただいて
違いがわかりますでしょうか
わかりますね
綺麗に歩くと美脚に見えるんです
男性の皆さん綺麗な子は好きですか
大好きですよね
私は大好きです
これはただ綺麗に見えるだけではありません
本当に美脚になっていきます
例えば膝を曲げてこういうふうにドスドスと歩いてしまうと太ももの前ばかり使って
しまって太ももの後ろがたるんで太くなってしまうんです
逆にしっかり膝を伸ばして歩くことで太ももの裏側を持つ変えられる使えるので
引き締まった美脚になります
また
お尻もしっかり使うのでヒップアップにもなります
1日にだいたい8000回8000歩ぐらい歩いていますので
8000回エクササイズしてるのものですね
このように日常から
綺麗に歩いてきれいに筋肉を使うということが大事なんです
女性の場合は美脚ですが男性の場合はカッコよくなります
私が思うに綺麗に歩く一番のメリットは自信を持てることです
自信を持って歩けるようになると堂々としていてかっこいいですよね
また第一印象も良くなります
デートや
仕事の場合はプレゼンの場でも歩くときに第一印象ってとても大事だと思うんです
けれども
その第一印象に歩き方を見ている女性は6割もいるというデータがあります
私はまさに今きれいにあるけれどにしててよかったなと思っています
その他にも綺麗に歩くメリットはランニングでも役立ちます
歩くことの延長が走ることなので綺麗に歩けるようになると例えば膝を傷めにくく走る
ことができます
このように綺麗に歩くと美脚になれたりかっこよくなれたり色んなメリットがあります
皆さんお綺麗に歩きたくなってきましたでしょうか
ではですね
実際に今日は綺麗な歩き方のポイントを簡単に2つだけお伝えしたいと思いますぜひ
一度皆さん立っていただけますでしょうか
ここは結構幅が狭いのでちょっと横とか後ろに広がっていただいて
横向き左向きに一歩歩けるスペースを確保してもらえますか
ありがとうございます
では綺麗に歩くポイントの一つ目なんですけれども
キレイなるポイントは股関節を伸ばすことです
股関節のココですねここを曲げて歩くと
よくないんですけれどもしっかりここを伸ばす伸ばして歩くということが一番大事な
ポイントです
なので左を向いていただいて
一方
やっていきましょう
足かかとからついて前に体重をしっかりかけます
この時に太ももの上付け根のあたりをもうちょっと触っていただいていいんですけれど
もここが伸びているのが大事です
もう一度行きましょう
もどっていただいて
足を着いた時にここをしっかり伸ばす
これを感じてあることが大事です
じゃあ戻っていただいて
で綺麗にあるポイントの二つ目は親指の付け根に体重を乗せることです
人を立つときに踵と親指の付け根と小指の付け根の3店で立ってます
今皆さんこう足の指をちょっと上げていただいて立つとこの3点で立っているというの
がわかります
このかかとから親指の付け根に向かってまっすぐ体重を移動させることが大事です
ではやってみましょう
横を向いていただいて一歩かかとからついて
親指の付け根に向かって体重をのせます
そして前に体重を乗せ切りましょう
姿勢もちゃんと上にあげてやっていきます
五回戻りましょう
かかとからついて親指の付け根に向かって体重をのせます
で前に体重を乗せ切れます
ok です戻ってください
では元に戻って一度教わりください
このように親指の付け根に乗せるとしっかりおよび日から買って前に進みやすくなり
ます
受信も左右にぶれないのでシャキッとした印象になります
この股関節を伸ばすということと親指の付け根に体重を乗せるということを意識して
まずは歩いてみてください
歩き方が変われば人生が変わります
女性は美脚になれたり男性はかっこよくなれます
デートやプライベートや
仕事の場でも自信を持って歩くことができ
第一印象が良くなります
またランニングやスポーツをする中でも足腰を傷めることなくできるのでずっと続ける
ことができます
そして将来の痛みを予防します
いたのことがなければ年をとっても自分の足で歩くことができます
あることができれば自分の好きなことをずっと続けることができますよね
歩き方が変われば人生が変わると言えるのではないでしょうか
人生100年時代確かに高齢者の割合は増えます
しかし介護が必要な高齢者ばかりではなく
自分の好きなことを楽しんでいる人ばかりの世界だったら素敵だと思いませんか
例えば私はハイヒールを履いてー
おしゃれを楽しんでいる80歳のおばあちゃんとか詩吟や釣りを楽しんでロボおじい
ちゃんが好きです
おじいちゃんもおばあちゃんも子供から大人までみんなが自分の人生を楽しんでいる
そんな未来は素敵ですよね
そのためには100年使う自分の身体を大切に使わなければなりません
自分の体は100年使うんです
自分の身体をきれいに使いきれいに歩き
豊かに暮らす
伝統工芸でもスポーツでも音楽でもなんだっていいんです
自分の体を大切にしながら豊かに暮らす
そんな未来に私はしたいと思います
最後でありますが今日話を聞いてくださったみなさんが今もこれからも幸せてい続け
られることを願います
ご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]